と非 黒でないというのったら
まだ全てのものが入って
ですからこの非入れることは
仏教の世界ではもう大変考えてる
それをもうインド的な哲学的な思想方法なんです
そんなにたくさん入って困る時はきちんとしたものを何か入れるんです
これとこれと ですからこの論理ではそれディストリビューションという言葉使ってるようですけどね
まあ言葉の意味はどれぐらい広げるかと
言葉の意味は無制限に広げてほしい場合は入れるんです
無制限に広げて困る場合はきちんとした言葉を使っちゃうんです
そこから定義するんです
この意味だけですよ ですから
白と黒と言えばもう制限されているんですね
言葉は それには赤青は入りません
白いと非白いと言えば無制限ということが
ですから この怒りが消えちゃったら涅槃であって
怒りが消えちゃったら涅槃であって
無知が消えちゃったら涅槃であるという涅槃まで悟りまで語りたいんです
ですから 貪瞋痴と不貪不瞋不痴と
八正道も同じなんですね
正見があって邪見があります
そこではもうちゃんと正と邪と
分けてるんです 決まってるんです
なぜならば何が邪見かと決まっていて
何が正見かと またそこに決まってるんです
で 例えば正見にはパーリ語ではサンマーディティというんです
それは否定形はアサンマーディティなんですね
それ使ってないんです
ミッチャーディティ使ってるんです
ですから どこでも片っ端から否定形使って喋ってるんだという
そんなことではないんです
かなり厳密にこの単語を作る場合は
用語っていうのはすごい厳密にすごい智慧で
ですから 仏教勉強の言葉だけ勉強したって
もうすごい頭が良くなるんです
僕 本当に驚くべき言葉っていうのは
このドッカという言葉なんですね
すべての存在の状態は一言葉でまとめちゃいますから
それほどたった一つの言葉に全てまとめるということは
いまだに人間の世界 誰一人やってないです
全体を説明するためのたった一つの言葉という
どんな哲学でもないです
苦しみですよということで
ヨーロッパの哲学者は言うんだけど
彼らはまあ今何か一部を苦しみだと言ってるんですね
存在すなわち苦ですよというふうに言えるまでは智慧が果たせてないんです
そういう話になっちゃうと
まあ私は自分勝手だけに考えてるだけで
皆さんはわかりませんだからね
やめましょう まあとにかく不貪不瞋不痴で行動すると善行為
その時は心は八つ生まれるはずなんですね
で この前説明しましたから
ソーマナッサーガタン
ニャーナサンパユッタン アサンカーリカチッタン
ソーマナッサーガタン ニャーナサンパユッタン ササンカーリカチッタンと
ソーマナッサーガタっていうのは喜怒楽しみがあって
ニャーナサンパユッタン智慧があって
アサンカーリカ行動的な心
ソーマナッサーガタン ニャーナサンパユッタン楽しくて智慧があって
ちょっとした励む励んだところで行動する心と
いわゆるあまり活動的じゃない心とかね
そういうふうに分けてあって
それから智慧がない心があって
それからウペッカーサハーガタ
捨苦の心がありますから
八つ分けてるんですね
それは善行為をする場合は
そこでいいことをした人々がどこかに生まれ変わる
いいことの結果得る場合あります
その時はどんな心ですかというと
また同じ心使ってるんです
それはあのいじく心というんですね
ん？まだ大聖人 なんて言ったっけ
あ だい？だいじく心 テキストではあの何ページですか
三十一ページ 大いじく心
大いじく心も だいしんも同じ言葉同じなんです
ですから 別に勉強しなくても同じ言葉だから
このいじく心っていうのは結果の心
大体この場合は あの いじくしんの場合はだいたい生まれは決めちゃうんですね
このだいじくしんの場合は月の生まれが決めちゃうんです
そこ違うところなんです
違うところかどうか まあちょっと言いにくいんだけど
で 例えば我々はこの人間に生まれたんですね
生まれたっていうことは
心が現れたっていうことなんです
そうでないと生まれたと言えませんから
この世の中で心が現れた
私たちは私 私という心の波が現れたと
その心 その現れた心はいじくしんなんですね
過去のカルマの結果なんですね
で そこでこの基本的な心はすーっとあって
この基本的な心を使って我々は行動しなくちゃいけない
あの これはこんな感じなんです
例えば 人間はこの世の中で現れる瞬間であの DNA 構造されるでしょ
一旦 DNA のシステムが決まっちゃったら
死ぬまでもうどうしようもないんです
それこの組み合わせたプログラムでやらなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば 母親の DNA の父親の DNA のどんな情報が入ってあっても
新しく出来上がる生命にはその中で一部しか組み合わせないでしょ
それでもうどうしようもない
それっきりでは 我々は自分の DNA 変えることできませんから
それはどこまで科学を発達させても
DNA 自体は変えられませんから
人の細胞は全細胞を変えなくちゃいけないんだから
それは不可能です 一個一個の細胞の中には全部 DNA 入ってるんだから
DNA 組み立てて新しい生命は作られますよ
いとも簡単に 一旦できている生命の変更はまたできない
ですから このそこら辺はもうこれからも科学者はどんなに研究してもできないと思いますよ
カルマだと 例えばお腹の中にいるいろんな微生物のは違う微生物に入れ替えることはできます
それしかできない あるいは DNA を研究して
子供が生まれる前に この子供は何歳で病気になるか
何歳で癌になるかとかね
もう後からあと十年ぐらい経つとそこまで言えるぐらい発展するかもしれませんよ
自分の運勢は全部言ってくれるんだと
DNA 鑑定で もうなかなか難しいんだけど
そこまでできても体一旦生まれた体の心の DNA 変わることはできない
ですから まあまあ それはそれで構いませんだけど
とにかく一旦我々がこの世の中で心がスタートしたら
その心で物を見る その心で音を聞く
その心で体を成長させる
その心 自分の性格は決まっちゃう
その心で考えたりする
ですから そこら辺はまあ
きつく決まっちゃうんです
で まあこういう説明でわかりやすいと思います
例えば人が何か素晴らしいいいことをします
それは善神なんですね
何でもいいんだけど いいことはね
まあまあ 例えばまあ酔っ払って
線路に酔っ払った人が落ちたところで
手を出し すぐ助けてあげたんだと
電車に轢かれる前にとかね
まあそういうのはいいことですけど
で そこで自分がすごく喜んでいいことできましたとかね
そこでその人は死ぬと
死んだところで この自分がいいことをしたんだから
その気持ちが このカルマが働き出して
それでどこかに生まれ変わると
生まれ変わったところで
この大心の結果として
彼がどこかで生まれ変わる
生まれ変わる場合は同じく意熟心の心が生まれる
生まれ変わった瞬間で
それから人間に生まれ変わったと仮定した場合は
そこでどんどんどんどんその人の体が出来上がっちゃうんですね
体が出来上がっちゃうと
眼耳鼻舌身も生まれてくる
その眼耳鼻舌身が生まれてきたら
その人は目で見たり 体で感じたりする
で それだけではなくて
自分が考えたりもする
体全体的なコントロールもする
性格も持っている そういう部分もあります
そういう全部意の働きで
心の働きで なんか今日は話がいくら簡単にしようと思ったって複雑になっちゃう
なんか悪い例でもついてるかもしれません
頭の中で一生懸命もう大工場みたいに働いてるのに
これいかにすれば簡単ですかと
いかにすれば なかなか簡単にならない
で まあ要するに 眼耳鼻舌身の働き以外
我々の心の働きがあるんですね
頭の中の働き それはこちらで考えているんですね
意熟心として そこで体の働きより心の働きの方が強烈なんです
人間っていうのは心で考えてどうにもなりますからね
元気な人はすぐ病気になっちゃうし
病気な人は心の働きで健康的になっちゃうし
だから心の働きはかなり強烈なんですね
体の働きより ですから
カルマの結果として 目で何か見て
ああ 悪いカルマの結果で悪いものを見ちゃったと思ったっても
そんな大した働きじゃないんです
こっち見たら悪いもの見えると
こっち見ればね 右見たら悪いもの見えるんだと
では右見ないで左見ようと
それはそれで終わりますからね
そんな大したことじゃないんです
でも我々のそれ逃れられないのは心の働きなんですね
例えばいつでも暗い考え方を持ってる人がいるんだと
その人はいつでも暗い考え方から逃げられないんですね
あなたはこの東京にいるんだから暗い考え方を持っていますよ
ですから田舎に行きなさいと
行って田舎に出す その人
田舎に行った途端に明るくなるんですか？ならないんです
そこでも暗いんです でも
目の場合は簡単なんですね
ああ 東京は本当に綺麗でもないし
まあもう本当に混雑してもう気持ち悪いんだと
じゃあもう広々している田舎に行きたいんだと思ったら
すぐもう見たらもう気持ちいいんです
目の場合は簡単です 耳の場合は簡単です
こっちうるさいんだったらヘッドフォンでもつけちゃって音楽でも聞けばすぐ終わっちゃいますから
そこはもうすぐカルマはね
いい方に持っていくか悪い方に持っていく
それとも簡単 でも心はそんなに簡単じゃないんです
なかなか治らないというか
ですから そこもカルマの結果で
人の性格とかね 好き嫌いとかね
生き方とか もう本当にもう治らないんですね
気づいたっても 自分の性格は悪いんだと
気づいたってもしょうがないんです
ですから まあいろいろもう治らないと言ったって
それは無常ですから 絶対的な話は全然ないし
もうそれはもうそれなりの努力すると
努力しろっていうことを徹底的に僕はやりますよ
性格は治りますよ 努力さえすれば
努力しないんだから 怠け者だから
そこは問題なんですね
だから仏教は怠けというものにはものすごい反対はする
人の努力にはケチつけるならば
どんな哲学でももう残酷に否定する
この皆様にはあの教えもありがたい
この教えもありがたいとか
そんなないんです どんな尊いと言われる教えだろうが
人の努力をけなしちゃったらもう全部ゴミだと捨てる
ですから 仏教の立場から言えば
このバガヴァッドギーターなんかはまあもう完全にゴミなんです
何のこともないんです
なぜならば 人の善行をしようと心を清らかにしようという努力はものすごい鋭く否定しているんです
それまた結局 仏教的な修行者の教えを盗んでやってるんだから
いわゆる清らかな心は欲もない
いわゆる善もない 悪もない心がいいや
正しいんだという聖者たちの人々の概念を盗んで俗人に喋ってるんだから
ですからもう修行して悟らない限りは
善も不善も働かない心は生まれませんし
ですから もうそんなに危ないんですね
そういう話って 社会は壊れてしまっちゃうんです
いいわけ例えば自分がシャットリア職で生まれたんだだから戦争するのが仕事だと
義務だと 人殺すなんて
人殺せばいいでしょうに
とにかく人殺せということをちゃんと言ってるんだから
そこで現代解釈ではそれは殺しじゃなくて
それはもう宗教的な修行のことを言ってるんですよと
解釈はどうでもいいんだからね
文字通りに書いてるものはもう戦争しなさいということだからね
だから昔書いた人を間違ってるか
今の現代の人を間違ってるか
現代の正しいことで 当時遠い昔バガヴァッドギーター書いた人を間違ってる
そんなまあ無茶苦茶な話ですから
どっちにしても どうでもいいんだけど
捨てた方が別取り場合早いし安全であるし
それでバガヴァッドギーター書いた人は戦争しようと言ったんだと
でもそれは間違っていたんだと
今 現代の哲学者の解釈は正しいんだと
言うと それまたおかしいでしょうに
本書いた本人がもう行って殺せと言ってるんだから
あるいは現代人の解釈は素晴らしいんだけど
それは間違っていて バガヴァッドギーターの方が正しいというならば
人殺しだから それまたおかしいし
まあとにかく結論できませんだからね
とにかくそんなものは捨てた方がいいんです
とにかく全部神様に決まってるんだよと
全知全能万能ですよ ですから
神がいるかいないかということまでにいかないで
仏教は 嘘だ 捨てましょうと
簡単に なぜならば それは嘘という人の努力を否定する
とことん努力しなくちゃいけないんです
常に常に自分の心に気づいて心を磨かなきゃいけない
だからそこはもうしか方法ないというものをきつく思ってるんですね
時の人間というのは 美しい言葉に引かれちゃうんです
このすごい綺麗な美しい言葉で聞いたら気持ちよくなっちゃって
ああ 素晴らしい教えだなと
日本でもいろいろ新興宗教グループいろいろありますけど
その中でも言葉は綺麗だ綺麗という言葉
ものすごいわかりやすく綺麗な言葉が並んで
美しい音 何て言いますか
文学的な日本語で喋ったりすると
そこでみんなそこを信仰しちゃうと
それは人間のちょっとした弱いところ
ところで 言葉に感情に引かれちゃうんですね
そこで智慧のある人は
あなたの言葉は美しいんですけど
それからやり方を見てくださいと
どうやればいいんですか？そこは必ず欠けてるはずなんです
もし人の努力の部分が欠けてるならば
もうどんな言葉美しい言葉の美しさに惹かれてはいけないのです
捨てればいい ですから
すごい頭の人々の美しい言葉よりも
田舎のおじいちゃんおばあちゃんのしっかりしなさいという言葉の方が立派なんです
怠けるんじゃないよとね
怒られるでしょ そちらは行動なんですね
行動しようと そこら辺は正しいんです
行動を否定すると 仏教もお釈迦様の立場から見れば
もう邪教になっちゃうんですね
ですから 仏教はあくまでも自力経であって
他力経ではないのです
他力経はもう全く合わないですね
で 仏教でも自力で言ったって自分一人で何でもできるわけじゃないんです
それはもう人間お互い心が繋げているんだから
もういろんな人を助けなければ自分が上に行かないというのは
それはまた別の話 だからといって他力だけでいこうと人のお世話になりますと
100% のそんなとんでもない話ですから
私は頑張りませんと あなたは助けてくれくださいと
あなたのせいではないかとと言うと
冗談じゃないんですね
ですから 自力と言ったっても
あなた方はどうでもいいという話でもないんですけど
一応中道的な立場なんですね
じゃあとにかく人間にはこの性格があるんだけど
それはほとんど直らない
もう生まれつきついている考え方やら心のエネルギーやら
もうどうしようもない
死ぬまでそれはもうその流れでいっちゃうんですね
それでも頑張ればもう何とかはなることはなるんです
ですから こちらでいじく心というのは
このほとんどこの生まれを作る心
これ起生心とも言うんですね
そういうのは後であと後の後で説明しますけどね
生人の生まれを作っちゃう
生起心 生生を起こす心
生起心ですね 一旦生まれたらその心の波でそのいわゆる生まれた心は死ぬんです
その瞬間で死んで次の心が生まれる
でも次の心が生まれたってしても
この前の心の能力と同じ等しい能力で次の心が生まれるんだから
そんな大胆な差がないんです
ですから いつでもそんなもんなんですね
そこで徐々に徐々に自分が心は清らかにしようと思っちゃうと
徐々に徐々に前の心はほんの微かに次の心は良くなるということがあるんです
ほんのわずかまた次の心良くなるということがあるんです
そういうことで やがて結構立派な清らかな心になる可能性はあるんです
ですから 悟りというものは人間には可能なものであって
他の人には不可能ですけど
それからとにかく生まれた心が
いわゆる元々の心があって
その心がなくなって その代わりに新しい心が生まれる
その心がなくなって その代わりにまた新しい心が生まれるという
この消滅の流れで心がつなげていくんですね
それでまたもう一つシステムがありまして
我々の心っていうのは
例えば人の話を聞く その時はすぐ目が覚めて人の話を聞く
終わった瞬間 我々は自分に戻るんです
一般的に見たっても 人の話聞いて終わったら
瞬間自分の世界に戻って
それから次のことに行くんです
いつでもそういう働きがあるんです
例えば私は喋ってますね
喋っていて じゃあコーヒー飲もうと思っちゃう
喋っていながらすぐコーヒー飲むんじゃなくて
喋って自分に戻ってコーヒー飲もうと
で コーヒー飲んで終わったらまた自分に戻って
じゃあこれから喋ろうと
その次にこの自分に戻るという働きは
ものすごい瞬間瞬間に起こるんです
今説明したのは長い時間の間の働きだって
これ瞬間で起こるんです
すぐ心は自分に戻る なんとなく微かにそれは感じるでしょ
それは自分をこういう風に考えてください
自分の家にお客さんが来たんだと
お客さんが来ちゃったら
すぐもうかなり心が働いちゃうんですね
すごい強烈に そこで挨拶するわ
お茶入れるわ いろんなものをするわ
料理はするわ その人と話をすればもうかなり緊張状態でいるんですね
そこで自分のうちに自分の子供か旦那さんか誰かまたいて
何かやってほしいと と待っている
そこでお客さんがいるんだから
それをしやめることはできない
それでお客さんがじゃあ失礼しますと言って帰ると
帰った瞬間にあなたのこととすぐそこに行くんですか？行かない
お客さんがそれで挨拶して
じゃあではまたとか さようならとかなんとか言って
瞬間ふーっとして自分に戻って
ああ あなたのあれですねとかね
次にそこに行くんです
もう自分に戻らなきゃ次の行動には移れません
そこは我々の大雑把な行動の中でよく見えるんです
それでこの 例えば 10 分間お客さんと喋ったならば
まあその 1 秒 2 秒は自分に戻って次のことにいくとか
例えば 1 日中ある仕事をしたならば
次の 1 日自分の世界に戻っちゃうでしょ
休んじゃうでしょ 例えば 5 日間仕事をすれば
2 日間休みを取っちゃうとかね
それ自分のところに戻るということはあるんです
日本ではかなり精神的な病気の人々が多いのは
この それはやらないんですね
威張って欲張りで休まないでしょ
みんな 休まないのは美徳だと
ふざけているのはもう大変とんでもないんだと
ですから 日曜日になってくると
日曜日はどうするんですかと
日曜日の仕事を探すんですね
だから体も壊すですし
心も壊れるし なんかちょっと自分にはちょっと何かふざけて
自分なりにリラックスして生きていられる休み場所をどこかになければいけないんです
それは場所でもいいし
心のところでもいいし
何かなければいいんです
いけないんです 自分一生会社だよと
一生家庭の面倒を見ることは自分の一生だよと
それだったらもう必ずもう精神的には至ってしまっちゃうんです
何かちょっとホッとするところがなければ
それは自分に戻ることなんですね
ですから そこは大事にした方がいいんです
明るく楽しく生きる まあエネルギーをね
ちゃんと死ぬまで消えないように持ちたければ
じゃあとにかくそれはその心はそういう働きで
何か仕事をしたらすぐ自分に戻って
それから次の働きに行く
そういう働きだから それはどんどん時間短くしてみてください
心っていうのは光の速度より 17倍速いんだから
光は物質だから 光のこの振動する瞬間は 1 秒間の何分の 1 ですかね
ものすごいですね まあかなり我々の体現できる範が決まってますけど
とにかくすごい速さなんですね
まあ音にしたらね  40メガヘルツでも聞こえるでしょう
これはすごい回数でしょ
1 秒間の中に 変化する回数っていうのは
それ物質それ認識するんだから心が
心はより早く行動している
心なんだ ですから 波の回数が早ければ早いほど
個体として感じちゃうんですね
また悪いことを まあそれはそれでこの
心がこの 1 日ではなくて
我々は 1 時間に縮んでみて
1 分に縮んでみて  1 秒に縮んでみて
それからさらに一番小さな認識の一つの単位に縮んでみた時
1個の認識 いわゆる目を開けた瞬間で壁を見えたと
それは一つの認識なんですね
次に壁の色を見る それまた違う認識なんです
次に他の何かを考える
それはまた違う認識なんです
それは 1個1個認識単位ごとに心が自分に戻っちゃうんです
だから自分に戻る回数っていうのはすっごい早いんです
ですから 我々はいつでも自分という実感があるんです
自分がいるわけじゃなくて
ただだから実感が生まるだけなんです
本当は自己がないんです
あまりも自分自分自分という意識に戻るんだから
戻る回数があまりにも早いんだから
自分がいるんだという誤解が生まれるんです
ですから 世界の宗教は
初めは私があるいるというところから始まります
仏教はそれは間違っていますというところから始まるんです
ですから 仏教の仕事は
自己があるということはなぜ間違っているかという説明であって
他の人 哲学者の仕事は
この自己について語る哲学である
だから ついて語ることはいくらでも語れますよ
何々についてだから でも他の哲学者誰一人自己はこれこそと見つかったわけはないんだから
ただすべて喋る それはいくらでも喋られます
そういう差があるんです
かなりの差なんですけどね
それで私が今日言いたかったのはカルマのことだから
この そこら辺にちょっともうなんかもうどうしようもないとこ見えるんですね
例えば私たちはこのある仕事をしたんだと
それですごい元気になっちゃうんですね
ああ 仕事できるんだと
その自信満々な状態ですぐ次の仕事をすればいいんです
そうはしないんです 心の働き
また一旦自分に戻って
次の仕事に行くんです
また同じくスタートから仕事しなくちゃいけない
そうすると いくら温かくなって元気になってしまっても
次の仕事に行く前にまた一旦自分に戻って
また最初からスタートなんですね
そういうわけで 人間はいつでも同じレベルなんです
いつでも同じレベルにいるんです
カルマからはなかなか逃げられないんです
情のよるよよよとか いくら頑張ってもなかなかやられないんです
瞬間瞬間 元の自分に戻るんだから
ということなんですね
ですから 我々のこの今考えている心自体も
一応原材材料としてできたのは過去のカルマの結果だからね
ですから 結局もっとわかりやすく言えば
我々の思考パターンも
カルマの結果なんです
ですから 私はもう何でもすごいややこしく考えちゃう
それはもう昔から同じことで
こんな年取って脳細胞半分以上死んでいるのにまだ治ってないんです
いわゆる考える内容は変わるんだけど
それについてすっごいもう多次元的に考えるんですね
自分でもなんでそこまで考えるんですかと思うほど
夢見ても夢見ている間でも
そこでこうやってああやってこうやってこうやってと自分全部考えちゃうんです
疲れる 疲れちゃいますけどね
夢見とっても で おかしいんですね
何か何か美しい夢を見たっても
こんなことあるはずがないんだって世の中で
なんでそういう風になる？これおかしいと
あるいはあるならば なぜそういうことあるんですかと
まあこれはおそらく夢でしょうと
で 夢 だからそれについて考えちゃうね
それで同時に夢を見るんです
全部同時進行で だからそれはこちらの性格で
皆様方はまた皆様方の性格で
それそれなりにもうどうしようもないものなんですね
付いているカルマからは逃げられないんです
大体まあそれぐらいのことでね
で あの八種類があるんで
成熟心が ですから 私たちが生まれた心がシャグーの心だったら
そんなに明るい人間じゃないんですね
奇遇の心だったらよくよく明るい人間で
この子供たち見ればわかるでしょ
この赤ちゃんの時でもよく笑う赤ちゃんたちがいて
また全然笑わない 泣くだけ
泣くのは別にそうしたことないんです
それはどうせ子供泣くんだから
それ置いといて あの あまり笑わないというもいるんですね
で 大人になってもその性格は変わらないんですね
だから よく人を観察してみてください
何でもすごく気持ちよく
楽しく笑ったりという
すごい明るい性格の人がいて
またすごくクールで そういう性格の人もいます
何でも人のことを聞きたくて聞きたい
食いばっかり聞いちゃって
小さい時から死ぬまでその連中はそんな感じなんです
気持ち悪いんだけどね
まあ治らないんです そういう人に瞑想を教えたって
自分で瞑想しながら あんたどうやってやってるんで
だからそういう性格 だからもうそこはもう落ち着いて見るしか方法ないんだけどね
私はきついんです 完全に無視するんです
そういう人たちは それは良くないんだけどね
自分の性格だから自分勝手にひどい目遭ってください
手出しもしないし で そこも私のきつい恐ろしい性格ですけど
なかなかそれもまた治らないんですね
そんなに厳しくしないです
だから思って だから昔はそんな厳しい人間でしたけど
今はまあどんな悪いことを見たても全然もう何も腹が立ったり
もう何もないんだけど
それでもあの厳しさはどこかでやっぱり活動はしているんです
親切さを装って 今は厳しさ活動してるんです
まあほっときましょうと
人のことだから そのほっとくこと自体も
またすごい厳しいというかね
気にするなと 気にする必要ないんだと自分に言ってるんだけど
この気にしないこと また自分の性格から解釈すると
それまた厳しくすることになっちゃう
ですから もう性格っていうのはそういう風に
このきついものなんです
で そこで一番大雑把に 2つに分けてますけど
奇遇とシャグーと 奇 まあそれよりはまたまたいろいろあるかもしれません
で 私はよく人観察するんだから
もう何があっても笑っている人々はいるんですね
例えばそういうよく笑う人々は
この漫才師の人々じゃ
それは職業だから それで性格とは違うんです
[笑い]心が優しいかないかそれでは決められません
で たまにこのいろいろこの演芸やってる人々
この悪役やってる人々もいるでしょ
あれ悪役に選べるのは結構根元はこれは明るいんです
だから悪役に選ばれちゃうんですね
悪役見てるとすごい楽しくてしょうがないんですね
悪役を見て本当に気持ち悪くなって
もうお腹が痛くなっちゃうと
もう俳優さんになりませんだからね
この最近終わった あの
何て言いますか NHKの朝のドラマでも
あのすごいちっちゃな女の子がなんかすごい悪い言葉言っちゃうんですね
あれすごい可愛いというかね
あれだけ僕はあのドラマ気に入っちゃって
あの子であのなんとかって
あれだけ可愛くて ただ
そのためにそのドラマ見たんです
あれですから いわゆるちっちゃな女の子ですから
どうせ可愛いしやってることだから
もうすごいきつい言葉言っちゃっても
結局可愛いってことになっちゃうんですね
だから根元から暗くてきつい人がそんな言葉を言っちゃうと
またそんな美的な味は出てこないんです
ですから このとにかくこの人の笑ってるということは性格のことで
よくニコニコという性格の人がいて
そういう人々は葬式とかそういうところに行っても
みんなとにかく雰囲気を楽しませちゃうんですね
だからって笑わせることはしない
だって自分の誰か亡くなってるんだからね
ですからもう笑うんじゃなくて
なんとなくなんかいると雰囲気がいいというかね
そういう性格があるんですね
で それによって我々今羨ましがったってもしょうがないんです
私もああいう性格になりたいなと思っちゃっても
この基本的な心だからね
それから基本的な心を直さなくちゃいけないんですね
そこはほとんど不可能と等しい
で あの まあコンピューター用語使うとよく分かりますけどね
まあみんなあまりそこを使っても理解しませんだけかもしれませんだけどね
であの自分の心を直すために自分が直す
自分がそれをしなくちゃいけないでしょ
自分の心が自分の心を直さなくちゃいけないんだから
自分のことを別に出して直そうと思ったらできないんですね
心がそれをしなくちゃいけないんだから
ですから 徐々に成長する手法
方法しかないんですね
まあまあ諦めた方がいいですね
それよりはもっといいことをポジティブにしようと
で まあそれはカルマで結果として
それで一旦終わっちゃいますが
次の8セットに行きます
先生ちょっと質問していいですか
はい  今のヴィパーカですね
うん  これはあのクサラなんですよね
うん  どっちかっていうと
どっちかということというか
もうあの この場合は大念処の場合アクサラしかないんですよね
え？ 大念処 マハー・ヴィパーカの場合はクサラしかないって考えていいですか
うん  アクサラの有印の場合はクサラしかないって考えていいですよね
どっちかって断ってないですよね
クサラでもアクサラでも書いてないですよね
こういうことなんです
あの 不善心は12種類あるでしょ
一番初めに説明 不善心は12種類あります
不善心をしたならば あの7種類のアヘトゥカ
アプサラ・ヴィパーカ・チッタ
無因 不善 成熟心がありましたね
それは結果として得られる
そこでこちらでは大心といって8種類の善心が説明しました
そちらの結果として8種類の成熟心と8種類の無因
これパーリ語でしか言えないんだから
8種類のアヘトゥカ・クサラ・ヴィパーカ・チッタっていうのありますね
そこは生まれちゃうんですね
じゃあ15種類  16種類の結果が得られる
こうもうチャートいろいろ勝手に書いてこなきゃわかりにくいかもしれませんだけど
まあ面倒くさくてやらないですね
まあ別にチャート書くまでのとこじゃないんです
僕にとってはもう もっと難しいとこありますからね
まあまだ思い出してください
18種類の心が説明しました
その18種類の心の中で3つは置いておきます 15
は善と不善の結果なんですね
そこで不善結果は7つありました
この不善結果の7つの心が12種類の不善心の結果なんです
悪いことをすると心が12種類が生まれる
その結果報いが味わう時は7種類の心が生まれるということ
で 不善の世界は終わり
善の世界はいいことをする場合は 8
種類の心でいいことをする
その報いを受ける場合は